[Musique]
le conseil de classe de top chef les
chevriers c'est la saison 10 de top chef
et on va noter l'émission
alors hier 2,6 millions de
téléspectateurs maximus mais elle baisse
de 100 multiplicateur sur une semaine
mais en tout cas la vitesse de croisière
est bien là et cette saison millions 5
hier et 2000 au fait ça est donc
supérieure d'une saison à l'autre ça
progresse en part d'audience et au nom
de téléspectateurs j'aime bien alors la
saison 10 donc ça bah ça ça passe quand
même un voilà où ça passe très bien même
c'est donc autant qu'avant une nouvelle
saison le monde entier sur alors on va
voir les notes des chroniqueurs et on va
revenir sur plusieurs moments forts du
programme
on a pu voir le chef arnaud lallement
hier on a remarqué un truc lui il est
comme toi du bris et les fans de sauce
ils sont si vous cuisinez passé je vois
que fascicule rien j'adore avec les
étoiles petit lob parfait pour cent y 3g
2 si tu sais que je t'aime en plus mais
je suis blessé mais âge et ma surprise
pour toi ouais j'attends je l'attends
mais toi tu veux te compte en quoi tu
fais quoi à tout mais quoi je suis tout
c'est quoi ta spécialité genre compte
aussi tu ma vie cathy d'affaires moi je
mes enfants adorent mais sauce tué de la
grillade fait des choses qui vont avec
ce que l'on montre un barbare mais je
suis sûr que tu aimes tu as jamais
phaneuf dont je me nourris regardez hui
les fans de sauce regarde moi
l'assemblée française c'est la sauce
chose que j'aime bien faire dès le
départ c'est la sauce
et à la sauce à côté on va goûter la
sauce la seule c'est magique je sais pas
si c'est un candidat qui vous a souvent
fait les sauces ou si vous en fera
encore beaucoup dans les prochaines
épreuves
mais il faut qu'ils fassent des sources
parce que l'associé de très près l'air
[Applaudissements]
hier ça c'est pas mal vannes et hier
dans l'émission vous allez voir on va
voir une compil dans un instant jean
michel maire a mis 3 g 8 3 suisses la
dixième saison et voilà j'adhère
toujours pas dans ce sens que on peut
regarder d'als bah moi d'halsou ma
meilleure c'est shy'm on peut regarder
the voice et kenshi le top chef sera
incapable de dire quels les meilleurs
cuisiniers
voilà il ya des plaques ce que vous avez
dit à chaque fois parce qu'elle est là
parce que c'est ça ne change pas autant
que se trouvera pas goûté des plats
visuellement et ben voilà donc du coup
on fait confiance aux chefs mais moi
c'est pas interactif je me sens pas
impliqué dans le programme
je suis certain que qg plus bien mais
voilà mais je voudrais pas rentrer
dedans donc je peux mettre que trois
merci en tout cas on a bien joué mon jeu
a vraiment débat alors isabelle on
savait que vous allez mettre une bonne
note 6 cm 6 9 sur 10 alors moi je n'ai
pas 10 parce que c'est un peu trop long
il faut poser un rtt pour le regarder en
entier c'est vrai
à part ça pour moi c'est un orgasme
télévisuelle tout simplement la vida qui
sont très attachants d'ailleurs c'est
pas top chef c'est top sexe parce qu'il
ya des mecs super sexy et franchement on
se régale là dessus il ya des chefs pour
super boulot moi c'est pas bon signe
pour les ménagères me disais que ça
fonctionne c'est important aussi d'avoir
des jo mais qu il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion hier on l'a vu avec les
familles qui ont déboulé avec la
déclaration de florian sur sa maladie de
la rate donc franchement c'est émouvant
on pleure et en plus on salive donc un
régal quoi alors y'a merouane qui est
avec nous merci me juan garcès donc
merci que voilà un autre qui fait dans
l'émission je vous ai parlé de toi car
tu aimais beaucoup faire des jeux de
mots et des punchline ouais tu faisais
tu as tes l'émission puisque tu kiffes
la cuisine aussi tu t'es dit je vais me
faire remarquer parce que j'ai envie de
faire de la télé bas la cuisine la
cuisine c'est mon métier depuis depuis
l'âge de 16 ans j'ai commencé la cuisine
t'inquiète pas et oui la cuisine bien
sûr c'est mon métier c'est ma vie depuis
bientôt treize ans et la télé j'ai
toujours aimé ce côté spectacle show je
suis passionné de théâtre et l'aquifère
top chef ou par jennifer touch est
vraiment à rien à reprocher à la
production bas j'ai eu à reprocher non
franchement c'était cool pour moi c'est
une cour de récré de presque deux mois
tournage systar faire chine tout de
suite alors on regarde tes prestations
regardes tu faisais beaucoup de jaune ou
rouge où il est pas chasseur mais il
termine cartouches et de trois coups de
couteau à la japonaise
hamon a donné marrer c'est un copain
cocada après le retail encore en deux a
par exemple sixième semaine j'ai la rage
à 8,2
tous les fonds c'est une petite raclée
quand même aujourd'hui on n'a pas été à
bordeaux courir le thème c'était le
canard fait un bide mots et malgré tout
pas besoin de mon handicap
là sur l'échelle de richter du bien-être
on dit bien remercier parce que tu as
fait une interview dans télé loisirs
télé que tu aimais beaucoup l'émission
web était heureux que tu sois là soir et
merwan au site a quitté l'aventuré sans
que c'était mercredi dernier tout est
triste la semaine dernière pour toi qui
va gagner
qui va gagner je peux pas dire parce que
c'est pas uniquement sur les prestations
culinaires c'est vrai qu'il ya une
grande part de chance dans top chef
ouais voilà moi je me suis entendu bien
avec tous les candidats je vais pas dire
untel ou untel c'est tout si on est là
c'est qu'on était tous des bons
cuisiniers à la base après c'est vrai
qu'il ya une grosse part de chance pour
aller jusqu'au bout et j'ai pas de papa
tu a pas de favori alors qu hier
l'ambiance était plutôt bon enfant
ça rigolait c'est pas mal vanille on a
fait une compil regarde un moment il va
falloir qu'il ya un peu de peps par
ailleurs où tu te sens vraiment
alors tentant est ce qu'il fait bien la
cuisine rien ça donne envie
l'inversé est faux plat il me semble
bien que c'est déjà sur la carte des
neurones crâne d'oeuf
ne t'inquiète pas peur
ça rigolait géraldine maillet on était
huit vous aimez oui moi j'adore je moi
c'est mon émission préférée est la seule
que j'aime sur m6 avec capital aux
ordures
bah non je déteste tout le monde accepte
une allée j'adore top chef bien sûr vous
savez j'adore m6 parti et surtout j'aime
la cuisine j'aime manger
j'aime cuisiner et je trouve que ça lui
véhicule que des bonnes valeurs quoi ça
veut dire que si un jour on va sur m6
vous ne suivez pas sur m6 ouais bah
c'est parce que si c'est vous c'est bien
vous oh lola la crainte réelle valeur
aujourd'hui l'autorité la transmission
la discipline le secteur
voilà quoi et ben moi ça tombe bien j'y
serais déjà parti que les hommes mettent
des mauvaises notes et fan de ben c'est
vrai j'aimerais alors à nord est banale
et en même temps que gilles & co kg
l'éco-habitat top chef n'a pas compris
une autre émission
alors c'est quoi comme chef bien on va
chez quelqu'un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma cité celui de connaître ses droits
d'émission il a confondu aka dîner
presque parfait c'est t'as pas compris
il presque parfait il ya un chef un chef
il va nous expliquer top chef quelques
alors boxe loisir explique tout objet
top chef il ya des apprentis des
apprentis cuisiniers qui parce qu'ils
essaient et des plats face à un grand
cuisinier connu réputé de la once and
for et tpm payer des apprentis
chroniqueur alors là c'est pas mal alors
hier ces dames n'a qu'à quitter
l'aventuré
il ne pâtisse epra pas donc aux quarts
de finale votre vote trouve être le gars
sur qui ou quoi le gars sur qui vous est
il et florian qui est d'ailleurs pas
très copain avec toi elle a été à
l'écouté prendre un verre avec lui ben
non mais dites moi mais j'ai un beau
souffle sur vous mais quoi on va finir
gentiment refusé de classe on s'occupera
de la demoiselle à j-1 dos mais ça ce
sera près du vrai qu'on voit
l'élimination de damien qui a bouleversé
des internautes et moi et il ya des
photos que j'ai vues de vous qui m'ont
bouleversé aussi bien dans des annonces
et rien n'arrive à c'est rien ça parlait
on m'envoyait des photos en teasing
quand même le petit vous envoyer des
photos mais mai puis vous croyez quoi
booster gold en gynéco vous étiez pas
dans une soirée dans la forêt ya pas
longtemps
ce week-end le week-end dernier dans
quatre ans ouais date
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans une soirée
je sais tout près d'euros disney sas est
dans le set c'est vrai j'aime aussi je
sais je sais je sais alors regardez nous
qu'est-ce que tu caf la 18e voix est-ce
que tu caf rien je note quelques che les
dessins deux ans qui dessine des tailles
mais qu'il ne dit jamais quoi chez lui
quand il rentre alors regarder vers les
médiations damiani il ya une assiette
nous a un peu moins
pour moins de plus quand même il faut le
dire
et l'assiette cochant faut en cas de
façon
c'est damien
qui a réalisé cette assiette
oui c'est bien moi vous l'avez compris
damien ça veut dire que c'est fait c'est
terminé désolé chef
[Musique]
je
alors damien s'est fait éliminer est ce
que vous comprenez l'élimination de
damien moi je personnellement je vous
sais m'en voyez les extras j'ai voulu
mathis d'accord beersheba c'est vrai
vous évoluez j'ai évolué comme dans
cette émission c'est très bien merci
illumination totalement logique parce
qu'ils étaient ratés sur les deux
dernières épreuves il est sorti sur un
mignon de porc humain juste peña
relation qui vous a donné à 40 pense pas
que ce soit alors on va demander
isabelle morini bosc
moi je trouve désolant que great
physiquement qui partent mais je trouve
que c'est relativement logique bien que
je me contrefous de la cuisine vous
savez j'ai prise elliott the prick
d'hélium non c'est un petit séjour dans
l'eau jeudi dernier est alors en
revanche il faut quand même noter adoré
l'émission alors pourquoi moi j'aime
beaucoup l'émission à cause du jury et
de la personnalité des candidats les
plages les ferai jamais moi j'aime que
les sauces ça sert à lima accompagner
les plats des missions vous parlez dans
l'émission les miss elle remplit
totalement sa mission qui est de former
des professionnels qui peuvent aller
n'importe où et il ya quand même quatre
candidats de top chef qui sont au guide
michelin cette année ses formes il était
du genre on trouve il était en en trombe
et à ce qu'on peut dire une somme
comprend très chez elle ce qu'est ce que
vous voulez à la laisser là par les
caisses que vous êtes à qui ils ont été
nommé en janvier 2002 et a exhibé dans
les restaurants étoilés qui travaille au
top chef
non non non non c'est un corner de la
banane bah oui j'y vivais pour deux
raisons d'abord hier le niveau était
trop faible
hélène darroze leur fait faire des oeufs
vous rendez compte alors officier est
ridicule et deuxièmement je commence à
en avoir ras-le-bol des émissions où ce
sont les perdons qui deviennent
magnifique noir à des chefs qui n'avait
plus de candidats est bon alors on
redonne non quand vous n'avez plus de
candidats vous avez été mauvais vous
êtes direz vous alors on va voir on va
voir ce qu'on pensait les internautes
là les gens j'ai maté 21 j'ai zappé 79
79 % qu'est ce que vous dites à saint
mirren écoute chacun fait ce qu'il veut
mais moi je trouve que c'est une bonne
émission
6 mai qui a permis de regarder regarde
pas mais bien sûr moi je vends
l'émission parce que j'étais j'ai kiffé
la fer eba travers bonne émission tout
s'est passé super bonne ambiance et
après ça nous ouvre des portes
t'as quoi maintenant moi j'ai un train
là je fais deux en train de monter mon
restaurant sur paris très bientôt voilà
je fais comment ben justement chirac
comme des idées pour le le merouane
parce que non non je suis en train je
suis à fond dans les projets en train de
chercher non mais son top chef bah voila
je rêvais hamon reste en appel le pietra
louf leterme et suit le ba ba ça marche
le ba-ba mission avec un facilitateur
pour vous mission ça a été plus calme
[Applaudissements]